talking about the iphones look if you
don't have kids you probably have an
iphone because you got to have something
to keep you busy the iphone 6 it is
coming soon chinese website Tencent
which is like their big social media
site in china says that the new iphone 6
could enter production as soon as May
and launch this summer we've got an
image of the rumored iphone 6 there you
go is that the sexiest thing you've ever
seen in your life and my god will you
wait on line for 48 hours outside in the
freezing cold for that thing as you can
see the screen is a little bit bigger
we're getting a little more glass
instead of some of the the carbon or
whatever it is that it's a normally made
out of it's also gonna have a better
camera it's going to be slimmer but
slightly heavier and HD resolution all
that stuff I know we're we're sort of
jumping the gun on this thing cuz it
hasn't happened yet but this sort of
goes to what we're talking about with
Facebook we just can't stop this machine
right are we just in we're just in this
machine and it's going and we got let we
sort of have to talk about it because
these things do change how we
communicate and deal with each other and
all I hear people are killing themselves
over this iphone already those are just
the ones making it yeah exactly yeah uh
that's uh you got you always have to get
the next thing it's a status symbol it's
kind of like what a certain brand of
jeans label would have been at one time
or what kind of car you pull up in its
your next you don't need to be in your
car to show what car kind of car you
might have when you whip out your phone
right but I think people are starting to
go you know what the the 5s is going to
hold me why I got funny feeling about
that six not moving the way they predict
yeah yeah I think they may have run
their sequence out and certainly the
reports coming back from the Chinese
factories have not been addressed to the
point where people go I think that that
took a little nibble out of them okay so
let's jump on that for a second so is
part of it that people may finally get a
little fatigued because a hearing all
that stuff what actually is going on in
China because you know Apple has all
these commercials where they say
designed in cupertino right but they
don't say mange
it's very small on the back of your
iPhone but that's it so it's part of
made by the blood of mammalian children
yeah exactly i mean they literally are
jamming things in with their fingers
that's Jay really how it's being exactly
i mean i don't know i honestly wish that
that was that the kind of social
knowledge was the reason why it would
slow sales i haven't feeling that when
you put that image up on on there it's
just like you could have put a 5 on
there and i would not have known the
difference it's like hey and look at the
other angle of this phone it's like they
think they pulled the wool over our eyes
and i think that people are starting to
catch on to it like there's going to be
a 7 or 6 z coming out like two months
later it's like keeping up with the
Jones is just like it's becoming
redundant and it's ridiculous now
there's not even really any added
benefit on this new phone I mean they've
made it slimmer yet heavier of you what
a selling point that's what I want you
know like something that's slightly
smaller but like it's really weighing me
down I don't know I knew with shatter
Maddox cream yeah yeah that's coming too
oh there's a blue megapixel camera like
that's not you know shooting the pants
off anybody yeah is part of harlem
though that the technology we've gotten
to this point where the technology comes
so fast that maybe 20 years ago when it
was about a pair of jeans or it was
about a car the technology to make a
pair of jeans or what was in changed
every couple years you know i mean the
car would change every couple years but
now that changes exponentially every
week yes and is that so how do we
control this thing because it really i
genuinely believe it's changing our
brains it's changing how we reacted work
and talk to each other and all that but
is it too late to stop this thing we
could be invaded by aliens and we
wouldn't know because nobody looks up
it's depressing our spines and our necks
the vertebrae will just form downward
like this we'll have giant uber thumbs
of the future yeah i mean their studies
proving that there that people are
starting to have neck problems that
people are having hand problems because
they're always doing this piece how do i
did was that good oh god I'm gonna do
the restaurant being a my phone
yeah is also Apple part of the the
problem here like even though the
technology everybody has access to
technology that Apple used to be
remember their big 1984 commercial that
they were fighting the PCs big brother
and the PCs but now it's like Apple is
big brother now and it's like you don't
know how to to stop them and I say this
with all due irony because I have an
ipad and i have an iphone and i have
macbook so you know I'm part of the
problem but I mean the thing is the
stuff is very cool like as what does I
hit it I'm like God this can do so many
things ran back here bring it back here
so we can legitimately love it yeah and
I feel crappy about that bring it back
here it's it's but yes it'll be more
expensive yes but you would be the hero
and you would sell you could invent
something new and sell it just based on
the fact that you came back here we
would love you so much more if you did
that you know is that even possible
anymore because of the how big the
companies are because they buy everybody
the second any interesting technology
comes out we see this all the time
anything comes out google buys it and
then they incorporate into their stuff
or apple buys it may incorporate there
are no we don't have like we have tech
startups but they immediately get bought
and incorporated everything else instead
of a new gadget so it's part of the
economics team so it says I think it's
part of a larger picture it's the
gestalt of a global thing of all peoples
of all nations you know the
underreported revolts in Iceland and you
know the nations that are throwing all
their crooks out and all that stuff what
we're doing now is we're starting to
slowly wake up out of our sort of media
induced coma to join the rest of the
world's been doing all this for a while
now they're ahead of us on this yeah
there's they've already seen and are
familiar with the things our eyes are
just becoming familiar with about the
greed running here because we kind of
liked how comfy it was for us here was
like yeah I know but we got the good
version of it we're on the good side of
it and we aren't on the good side of it
anymore yeah well if you want to find
out more about the Iceland revolution
they literally had a revolution in
jailed bankers and change the system we
did a video on that a couple weeks ago
so just you can put that in the Google
and you'll you'll find it all right
you're one of the guys talking about i'm
trying I'm trying
give me a high five we're giving
something